hay muchos vídeos en khan academy donde
hablamos sobre factorizar polinomios
pero lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo
es realizar algunos ejemplos de
factorización de polinomios de grado
mayor vamos a comenzar con un
calentamiento digamos que queremos
factorizar 6x cuadrada + 9 x por equis
cuadrada menos 4 x 4 pausa en el vídeo y
traten de factorizar lo por su cuenta y
que quede como producto de varias
expresiones vamos a resolverlo juntos
quizás esto sea un poco diferente de
cómo lo han visto antes ya que esto está
parcialmente factor izado este polinomio
con grado mayor ya está expresado como
el producto de dos expresiones
cuadráticas pero quizás se den cuenta de
que lo podemos factorizar aún más por
ejemplo 6x cuadrada más 9 x tanto 6x
cuadrada como 9 x son divisibles entre
3x vamos a factorizar 3x aquí esto es lo
mismo que 3x x por cuánto tenemos que
multiplicar 13
para tener 6x cuadrada 3 por 12 6 y x
por equis es x cuadrada y 3x
multiplicada porque expresión es 9 x
pues 3 x por 3 es igual a 9 x pueden
verificar esto distribuyendo el 3x nos
da 6 x cuadrada + 9 x y que hay de esta
segunda expresión de aquí podemos
factorizar la pueden reconocer esto como
una cuadrática perfecta algunos de
ustedes se les puede ocurrir encontrar
dos números cuyo producto sea 4 y cuya
suma sea menos 4 y que sean menos 2 y
menos 2
esto es x menos 2 que podemos ponerlo al
cuadrado o escribirlo x 2 x x 2 si lo
que acabo de hacer les parece poco
familiar los invito a que regresen a ver
los vídeos sobre factorizar cuadrados
perfectos y cosas por el estilo pero ya
lo tenemos creo que hemos factor izado
esto lo más posible
ahora resolvamos un polinomio con grado
mayor ligeramente más complicado
queremos factorizar algo más intrincado
x al cubo menos 4 x cuadrada más 6 x
menos 24 como siempre los invito a que
pausa en el vídeo y traten de resolverlo
pero les voy a dar una pista en este
caso podemos factorizar por agrupación y
de cierta forma es más fácil de realizar
comparado con lo que hemos hecho antes
por lo general cuando aprendemos la
factorización por agrupación vemos una
cuadrática y nos fijamos en el término
de en medio el término x de la
cuadrática y lo descomponemos de manera
que queden cuatro términos aquí ya
tenemos cuatro términos así que traten
de resolverlo vamos a resolverlo juntos
no siempre se puede factorizar un
polinomio de tercer grado por agrupación
pero a veces sí se puede por lo que vale
la pena intentarlo cuando lo vemos
escrito así decimos muy bien x al cubo
menos 4 x cuadrada hay algún factor
común aquí pues si tanto x al cubo como
4x cuadrada son divisibles entre x
cuadrada
factor izamos x cuadrada y queda x 4 y
que hay de estos otros dos términos hay
algún factor común entre 6 x y menos 24
si ambos son divisibles entre 6 factor y
zemos 6 aquí nos queda más 6 por x menos
4 y ahora probablemente ya se dieron
cuenta de que estamos en la recta final
tenemos algo x x menos cuatro más
otra cosa que multiplica a x 4 por lo
que podemos de distribuir x 4 o
factorizar x menos 4 por lo que queda x
4 x x cuadrada más 6 y terminamos